and so then I'm like nobody I know knows
I'm here no one I know even knows that
I'm friends with this forest so no one's
gonna come look for me
[Music]
what's wrong with junior
you know from the show baskets perfect
Eliezer
my story is about the ups and downs of
friendship specifically between me and a
horse that did did not belong to me but
whose pasture I climbed into because I
thought it would bring us closer
together and it came close to tearing us
apart so but just backtrack I the only
thing I knew about horses when I met her
is that I thought that they liked
carrots and apples and so I met her
because I had moved back to Austin in
2012 and I lived in a part of the city
that was almost out in the country and
there were a few places that had horses
and one day when I was walking my dog
this horse came to her fence and she
walked the whole length of her fence
along with us and then when we were on
our way back she did the same thing in
the other direction and she started
doing that every day and I never saw any
people in her pasture so I thought that
she probably wanted me to go pet her
because I thought I thought I had heard
that horses are like really big dogs but
I honestly believe that when people say
that if someone says that it's because
they were dealing with a big dog that
they thought was a horse because they're
not anything like dogs and I finally I
went to pet her and at first she would
kind of back away and then she finally
let me pet her and there were some early
signs that there might be trouble down
the road
did a couple times look like she was
gonna try to bite my hand and then one
time on my two I turned my back on her
and she grabbed my ponytail and pulled
it really hard but I thought that that
was like maybe how horses play and I
didn't know and I forgot to say I'd
started bringing her carrots and an
apple every day I would walk my dog and
stop and give her and so I thought that
we I thought that's um like you could
easily buy my friendship if he brought
me a good snack every day so I felt and
she seemed to like it
so so this is where things kind of go
south but it started it seemed at first
like they were we were entering a new
phase because I found I took my dog in
for a checkup and I found out that he
had a really fast growing untreatable
type of cancer and that he probably only
had a few weeks to live and I know
that's not a great topic for a comedy
show but but it's relevant to the story
so that I was devastated because I that
he was my first dog I totally treated
him like a person and loved him like a
person and I it's terrible that
someone's laughing at that part
that's really
that's that's in that's in poor taste
but so I'm just saying I'm not but it
was devastating and so I got the news
and I took him for a walk and I stopped
to give her her carrots and Apple and
for the first time she after she ate the
snacks she leaned over the fence and
pressed her forehead against my head and
just stood there and I thought like wow
horses are really sensitive like she
could sense that I was really sad that's
what I thought
in retrospect she might have been trying
to like psych me out or something I
don't know
I don't know but so then my dog passed
away and then I got another dog who's
great but that's not part of this story
um but so a little bit later
I kept visiting her and feeding her and
petting her and then I just one day this
this person so one day I think I don't
know it was going on with me but
probably some like reckless daredevil
once in a blue moon thing came over me
and I just thought I bet if like she's
like a dog I bet she would like it if I
was petting her inside her fence
[Music]
because that's what a dog would want you
to stand next to him and um I should
also say this had been a couple of
months or more and I never once did I
even just google horses it never
occurred to me to do that so this day I
just decided to I climbed the fence and
got in the pasture with her I thought I
would have like a story to tell my
friends later which I did but it wasn't
the kind of story I thought it was gonna
be like I was really courageous but um I
climbed in with her she ran away and
then she came back and then I just
walked next to her petting her and in a
soft voice talking to her and then she
kind of moved in front of me and turned
her back legs to me and then I went oh
this seems this is what horses maybe do
right before they kick somebody so I
stepped out of the way and then she
turned around and reared back on her
hind legs and started flailing her
hooves at me and whinnying and I still
wanted to think she was playing but it
was kind of terrifying so I just started
going no uh-uh no ma'am no
and then I ran and so she chased me
behind a tree and and she wouldn't leave
like she I thought made me she once I
got behind the tree and she can get me
she'd give up you know following and
then so at one point I looked over and
then her head popped out and so then I'm
standing there for maybe like 15 or 20
minutes I'm like nobody I know knows I'm
here no one I know even knows that I'm
friends with this horse so no one's
gonna come look for me I've never seen
any people come and take care of her at
one point a car slowed down and I they
were looking at me and instead of
flagging them down for help I thought I
don't want them to know that I'm an
idiot who finally here so I just gave
them the wave that's oh it's okay
we're okay over here and I found out
later I found out those were the owners
and late I went like that and they drove
away like I don't know they just has
some weird lady trapped behind the tree
with their horse and oh she waved I
guess it's fine we'll drive so they
drove so finally I saw this horse go
towards the other part of her pasture so
I slowly walk out from behind the tree
and start kind of trying not to upset
her walk towards the fence and then she
came back and chased me again so I ran
behind the little structure that she had
her hay in and then that lasted for like
another 15 minutes of having to wait for
her to get bored she walked away again I
ran behind another tree closer to the
fence and then the last the that was the
last tree that you know was the closest
to the fence and I thought it could make
it
so when she lost interest and walked
away I ran for the fence and in my mind
in movies when people take a run at a
fence they get they jump at the last
minute so they land right on the fence
and then they just throw a leg over and
they're done but um I ran at the fence
and I tried to jump but I still ended at
the bottom
I climbed it as fast as I could and she
was running towards me and I threw a leg
over and it got caught on my jeans got
cut so they ripped and then I finally
got to the other side and so at first I
really was mad at her and I felt like I
was like I know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna come visit her anymore oh shoot
we're like this is why I never see
people in her pastures cuz she's not a
nice horse
and then later I realize I have to keep
going to visit her because she's a
terrible horse and no one else is ever
gonna be friends with her so for the
rest of the time I live there I kept
bringing her food and um I wish there
was an ending of the story but thank you
for